in this video we're going to think about
how we can use our knowledge of
multiplying single-digit numbers to
multiply things that might involve two
digits so for example let's start with
what is five times 18 and you can pause
the video and see how you might try to
approach this and then we'll do it
together alright so if we're trying to
tackle five times 18 one strategy could
be to say hey can i reexpress 18 as the
product of two numbers and the one that
jumps out at me is that 18 is the same
thing as two times nine and so I could
rewrite five times 18 this is the same
thing as five times instead of 18 I
could write two times nine
now why does this help us well instead
of multiplying the two times 9 first to
get the 18 and then multiplying that by
five what we could do is we could
multiply the 5 times the 2 first and you
might be thinking wait wait wait hold on
a second before you did the 2 times 9
first and now you're telling me that
you're going to change the order that
you're going to say hey let's multiply
the 5 times 2 first is that ok and the
simple answer is yes it is okay if you
are multiplying a string of numbers you
can do them in any order that you choose
and so this is often known as the
associative property of multiplication
we can associate the two with the 9
first we can multiply those first or we
can have an association with the 5 and
the 2 we can multiply those two first
now why is that helpful well what is 5
times 2 well that's pretty
straightforward that's going to be equal
to 10 so this is going to be equal to 10
let me do that same color 10 times 9 now
10 times 9 is a lot more straightforward
for most of us than 5 times 18 10 times
9 is equal to 90 let's do another
example let's say we want to figure out
what 3 times 21 is
pause this video and see if you can work
through that there's multiple ways to do
it but if you could do it the way we
just approached this first example well
as you could imagine we want to
reexpress 21 as the product of smaller
numbers so we could rewrite 21 as three
times seven maybe and so if we rewrite
it as three times seven and now we do
the three times three first someone just
put parentheses there which we can do
because of the associative property of
multiplication fancy word for something
that is hopefully a little bit intuitive
well then this is going to be equal to
what's 3 times 3 it is 9 and then times
7 which you may already know is equal to
63 let's do another example this is kind
of fun let's say we want to figure out
what 14 times 5 is pause this video and
see if you can figure that out well we
could once again try to break up 14 into
the product of smaller numbers 14 is two
times seven so we can rewrite this as 2
times 7 or 7 times 2 and I'm running at
a 7 times 2 because I want to associate
the two at the 5
to get the 10 times 5 and then I could
multiply the 2 times 5 first and so this
is going to give us 7 times 10 7 times
10 which is of course equal to 70 one
more example let's say we want to
calculate 15 times 3 how would you
tackle that well we can break up 15 into
5 times 3 5 times 3 and then we can
multiply that of course by this 3 and
then we can multiply the threes together
first and then this amounts to 5 times 9
and 5 times 9 you might already be
familiar with this this is going to be
equal to 45 and another way to get to 45
you could say 5 times 10 is 50 so 5
times 9 is going to be 5 less than that
which is also 45